the Joe Rogan experience I think I'm a
conservationist and you know you know
we're talking in the tens of millions of
dollars go into conservation from
hunters every single day from from
hunting and you know the u.s. Wildlife
Department of Wildlife they don't know
how they're going to be paying for the
protection of habitats without hunting
permits because the number of people
that are hunting are shrinking so I mean
there's a huge influx in question of
about how moral are different styles of
hunting what are the best how are we
going to make sure that we protect these
animals and protect their habitats all
the while you know I was telling you
about that elk I shot at the beginning
of the year and I had I had a clean
broadside shot at 600 meters and I was
like I'm shooting a 308
totally super doable you know I can I
can do that almost in my sleep on my
home range but I'm shooting an animal
you know I was like no I mean let me
just walk this guy down another ridge
yeah so move upwind
come back down and my next shot was at
like 3 20 you know one shot and he sits
down so there I think the responsibility
always in all things should fall on the
individual but now it's just getting all
the individuals to actually have
responsibility that's where it gets
really really stupid yeah there's just
there's just people that they're not
good people they don't they weren't
raised well oh good
some people in in moments yeah what do
you mean when you say that like my mom
and I we argue about this a lot yeah
it's like she thinks people are
inherently good you know I don't Mike
well you've seen so much of the bad for
yeah obviously I'm gonna have a
calloused I'm not gonna have the most
objective perspective but like I what I
think people are good but like I think
hunters in jet let's just use that as
because that's what we're talking about
right now of a hundred hunters what
percentage are gonna do the right thing
are going to do the moral thing the
ethical thing the thing that's the best
interest for the animal for
servation for nature out of out of a
hundred you know if they're on a hunt we
say for sure the majority okay and now
it gets down to you know guesswork as to
what the numbers are but I like 60% more
I'd see more I like to think it's in the
70s or 80s I wish it was a hundred for
sure you know and I wish anything other
than that was just a mistake you know
but there's gonna be people that poach
it's gonna be people that cross property
boundaries when they know they're not
supposed to it's gonna be people that
shoot an animal when the season opens
tomorrow morning and they get there you
know a day early and they see an animal
and they just say [ __ ] it I'm just gonna
shoot it and hang it and say I shot it
the next day there's like gray area
stuff you know where you're you're
definitely doing something illegal but
it's still hunting you still have a tag
you know and it says people bending the
rules
yeah like when and then there's people
that just you know they'll shoot two
three animals I mean I was supposed to
shoot one they'll hide the meat yeah
there's there's there's always going to
be people like that [ __ ] yeah yeah
[Applause]